sur nos bureaux de très nombreux
télégrammes émanant de tous les horizons
politiques
chacun se réjouit de cette victoire sur
l'oubli et sur l'impunité pour reprendre
les propos du socialiste georges sarre
béate klarsfeld vous avez l'habitude de
avec votre mari serge d'exhumer ce genre
d'affaires
alors est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
toujours une bonne chose disons de
réveiller les mémoires qui flanche une
bonne chose que la lutte que j'ai
commencé 11 ans avec la réouverture du
dossier klaus barbie à munich et pij
démasqué en bolivie l'identifier ipv la
base de nonda demain je pense que c'est
une bonne chose parce que cet homme-là
s'est jamais repenti dans les interviews
qu'il avait donnée à la télévision à la
radio ou journaux il s'est félicité
d'être toujours un qui sait tenir hitler
il n'a pas changé d'idée
je crois que c'est une bonne chose que
cet homme-là soient traduits devant la
justice aujourd'hui quarante ans après
7,1
je dirais un procès symbolique qui
montrera le travail de la caste à pau en
france à travers lui sera donc montré un
procès historique surtout pour les
jeunes aujourd'hui il faut simplement
nécessaire de montrer comment c'est
possible comme la police politique a pu
bien torturé et tué les résistants mais
aussi c'est très important parce que
barbie a sévit aussi contre les juifs
c'est lui en 44 en avril qui a donné
l'ordre de déporter les petits enfants
juifs de trois saisons de houmed enfants
d'izieu et j'étais parti pour une
deuxième forme bolivie justement pour
mener campagne contre lui c'était après
la demande d'extradition de la france et
pour demander bolivienne qu'elle extradé
et d'un seul femme madame adeline brunet
qui avait dû les trois enfants et se
marier des fusillés par barbie je crois
pour elle c'est ce sera 10 ont une
solution qui s'impose parce que justice
au fait qu'est ce que vous avez dans ce
dossier jaune qui l'ont vu signifier ce
klaus barbie disons qui montre les
débuts comme j'ai commencé à m'occuper
de la sphère klaus barbie ce camp 70 ans
le procureur de munich avait fermé le
dossier quand barbie en disant qu'il n'y
avait pas d évidence pour prouver qu'il
devait connaître le sort des enfants
envoyaient ensuite en 44 et puis un
allemand au moment où justement une
faute de barbie été publiés dans la
presse allemande
un allemand vivant ali marc l'a contacté
en disant je reconnais dans la photo de
barbie de 42 et un homme d'affaires qui
vit entre lima et la passe sous le nom
d' iceman
et puis j'ai réuni en allemagne tous les
documents nécessaires pour identifier à
hermann barbie et bien je suis parti à
lima d'abord il a pris la fuite est allé
à la passe est un bolivienne je les suis
vie là bas et je convaincu je crois
l'opinion publique et le gouvernement de
leurs pertes lorsque vous êtes allemande
vous savez
répercussions que en allemagne et en
france ce procès va avoir vous pensez
que c'est une bonne chose il ne peut pas
y aura deux chocs en retour
certainement pas et nous avons mené avec
mon mari et des amis déportés résistants
des jeunes juifs surtout nous ont menés
en allemagne le procès contre richard
harrison et jeu de dire que nous avons à
part des juifs qu'ils nous ont fait
venir chaque fois avec la location des
fils et filles de france nous avons eu
aussi des jeunes allemandes dans l'art
dans la salle des séances
et puis je me rappelle toujours du
plaidoyer final du juge président du
tribunal qui disait écouter tournai
belgique a à g pour moi c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de juger
vu que vous pourrez être mes parents mon
père me perds mon père mais il faut le
faire c'est au nouveau aux nouvelles
générations de faire condamner les
crimes nazis pour que des choses comme
ça ne puisse pas se reproduire
merci pour votre témoignage du côté